hello everyone and welcome to some more
rapid action unleashes last game I
played was not the the best one I tried
the Evans Gambit and U didn't go all
that well but I've learned a lot and
hopefully that will not happen again so
I will try to play this one extra
carefully uh as probably I will get the
black pieces now so I have no idea what
I will play uh no I get white again very
interesting uh so we might we might get
a repetition depending on what what our
opponent plays my opponent is Mr alpha
alpha 2011
and we are going to go for e but no it's
a Sicilian Defense so we're going to
tackle it with Knight to F3 D6 all right
so standard stuff here captures captures
let me just fix that a little bit more
yeah could be could be anything probably
heading to a
nidorf uh I don't have like a like a
nidorf specialty repertoire but we're
going to go for H3 the the so-called
Adams attack and we're going to play it
with Knight to E2 uh going for G4 G5
ideas
uh looks like you're you're opening up
your position quite a bit early on but
um yeah shouldn't be shouldn't be that
big of a
deal okay so he allows it uh we're going
to we're going to advance our
pawns okay let's go let's go here
first maybe this was more precise but I
don't think we are that that you know
that um deep into stopping D5 okay so he
he wants to play he wants to play
B4 which yeah is
fine all right so some future plans
might involve getting the Knight to F5
maybe some Bishop to H3 action later so
do we need Bishop to G2 right away no we
don't and even if B4 yeah our Knight
could could very well be strong
here so what to do yeah but
maybe yeah we're going to play Queen D2
just prepare Castle's Queen
side uh it's a very very oddl looking
position yeah all the standard ideas are
here okay so he wants to get the Knight
to C4
uh makes sense of course we're going to
play this the free up our light Square
Bishop yeah now we're going to take give
give up one of our
Bishops yeah now it's actually very
strong when he captures with the bishop
because as long uh while the Bishop was
on E6 and for example if he plays Queen
A5 and B4 oh no he captures with the
Rook yeah very interesting very
interesting
stuff all right
so yeah he's putting pressure on e4 if
he plays this so we can play F3 I think
without without much problems yeah do I
need King to B1 I probably
do I probably
do yeah we'll see we'll see who's
faster we'll see who's
faster yeah okay next uh we're we're
ring to get that Knight Knight to F5
probably I have to play F3 first I mean
it's been long
overdue as both of the knights will move
at some point so we want the pawn
defended
but
yeah so what's uh yeah maybe even before
some Queen A5 action maybe the Knight
can come to to C5 maybe that will also
and be of some use to him yeah could
come with Tempo at some
point yeah so he's probably looking into
a lot of stuff here like Knight to C5
maybe he's looking into Knight B6 as
well probably not probably Knight C5
he's looking into B4 uh I I seriously
doubt it that he's looking at A5 but
it's it's a tall move so you have to
consider it uh you know might not be
completely yeah he just castles so we're
going to go for Knight
F5 yeah he takes and now he does have
the center but we are we are already
threatening to open up the position
so even at the price of some
material oh probably now the Knight
comes to D5
first yeah
um yeah I mean he he plays the Sicilian
so he probably knows his stuff around uh
positions that arise from the Sicilian
but I don't know I feel like I got uh I
I got more than I should uh from out of
the opening yeah and you guys said in
the previous video that my clock wasn't
showing so sorry about that let me just
fix that real quickly here uh let me
just check where the clock is no that's
not the clock no that's me
um sorry about that clock oh there you
go there's the clock yeah I have no idea
how that happened really weird
stuff just fix this a little bit like
this yeah sorry about
that no idea how that
happened okay it seems seems pretty
visible now uh but yeah yeah okay so he
goes uh yeah we're going to go Knight D5
there's no better way to do it oh what
he wants to free up this for The Rook
really is that is that
wise
um yeah I'm sure it is I'm sure it is
let's go Rook G1 if anything is going to
open up uh might be okay so now now I'm
not playing F6
anymore
uh as
he I'm going to play H5
first yeah but Knight D5 I mean it's a
move you always want to play yeah first
we're going to play Knight D5 simply
because uh now he doesn't have Queen A5
he doesn't have Knight to B6 as it's
defended twice and then we're going to
continue pushing on the king
side and I don't see much counterplay
for him like Knight C5 is always always
uh a move yeah he can play that whenever
he wants in pretty much all the lines of
the Sicilian yeah he goes uh Rook to C6
he really wants to get the Knight to
B6 so do we allow
that yeah let's
go let's go for the king probably Knight
B6 but we can even play G6 we don't have
to uh we don't have to resp expect that
Knight to B6 move at all I
think I'm trying to see if maybe we can
improve the position a little bit before
advancing no he doesn't want to do that
he's freeing up D5 Square for the
Knight
um how would tal play this he would
probably play something like G6 whatever
captures and then H6 regardless of what
happens he probably would play something
like this so we should we should play
what St would
play yeah probably something like
that I don't think he can just do
nothing oh he he he says he can do
nothing yeah okay so capturing while
always fun I think H6 first is the way
to go uh so we're going to do
that yeah I think this will this will
work out
nicely yeah other than like the Knight
moves he doesn't really have
much okay so what's the what's the
cleanest way of uh handling things here
there's even something like Knight
captures on F6 okay so now he stopped
that actually was it possible in the
previous move no no no sorry uh yeah it
was no it wasn't yeah it was Knight
captures F6 then Knight captures I still
don't have Queen D5 yeah so that's uh
that's a
shame uh but you know the Knight is now
pretty much stuck here but we can use
that to our advantage in the sense that
uh in the sense that we can just play
some
like Bishop to F4 cuz he wants to go
Knight C4 and then if if he does that we
can actually play Knight captures on F6
maybe no we can't yeah that would be a
fun line Bishop F4 Knight here Knight
captures on F6 Queen captures Queen D5
check he moves the king I take the rook
and he delivers Checkmate as the Knight
here is covering uh the B2 Square yeah
that's uh that's fun so we must uh we
must look into captures now
we were trying to avoid it
uh but
no maybe we can do it uh a little bit
differently
huh H I'm Prett pretty sure there's
uh
H yeah I thought it'd be it'd be much
much
cleaner yeah actually Bishop D4 I think
is the move that we have to play but no
then he has Knight to F3 H yeah he's
attacking on both fronts so I will have
to start capturing
something
yeah
definitely okay so of course he doesn't
want to take we're going to take here
but I mean I don't know why he wouldn't
take
it yeah I'm definitely going to
sacrifice The Rook now for the
bishop
uh
okay go here now I'm just checking if he
will take it if he goes here then I have
Rook G1 very annoying very
annoying yeah we're going to go Rook G1
now uh we're going to suffer through the
pin because he cannot do anything about
it yeah we're threatening Bishop G7 so
if he goes Knight F3 just Bishop here
and that's it game
over probably I'm I'm over complicating
things here uh but we'll
see yeah and the nice thing about that
Rook captures on G7 move was that my
knight is controlling C7 at D7 so I
don't have to worry about any of the
Rook moves trying to defend this bishop
to G7 move and the Knight really has no
way of Defending that so that was also
something I've I've considered uh a few
moves before Rook captures on G7 uh not
in this line in particular but uh yeah
it's important to
yeah I see that uh the Rooks will not be
able to help out with the defense of the
G7
Square all right so how does he defend
here if if he just captures which of
course he can do uh what do we
do we we just play Bishop G7 yeah I mean
we still play Bishop
G7 yeah I don't think there's a move for
him
here
yeah I mean yeah that that's the problem
with allowing a Pawn on H7 to survive
yes you do get to hide behind it but all
sorts of tactics are born
uh uh due to due to its presence on the
board oh yeah okay so he goes here uh
yeah that's a that's a nice move but it
doesn't
work unfortunately for him yeah Bishop
G7 as now we also gained access to F6
and that's pretty much it now he has to
give up his Queen
um we have to take the
queen yeah we kind of
do we have to take the queen but
probably he resigns now there there's
there's zero compensation for the
queen yeah he resigns all right so uh uh
he wants a rematch but it it will be too
long of a video it's already 15 minutes
and we uh we we cap it off it one uh one
rapid unless it's like that one game
where uh my opponent really blundered
really early on but yeah let's check it
out and also uh you guys said that you
want to see the engine bar during
analysis so okay let me just fix that as
well
uh where is this display thingy nope oh
there it is sorry yeah that's oh that's
also part of the clock all right so uh
let me just improve that a little bit
here uh so yeah there there's the engine
bar all right so the engine bar you will
know if it's uh you don't see the entire
engine bar but you will know if it's
better for white or for black so okay E4
C5 that's all pretty standard uh till H3
here okay I went back this is all very
nice G4 Bishop B6 G5 yeah okay H4 uh
Bishop B3 we actually play all the top
moves uh castles yeah very nice okay so
B3 here sort of uh being offered I go
Knight to G3 which is not the best as
I've obviously blundered with Knight to
G3 not the game but the sort of the
advantage yeah all sorts of yeah but I
don't know I don't know why B4 was that
big of a deal oh because of B4 kn5 and
B3 wow yeah definitely something to to
learn if you if you're if you play um
the Adams variation of the nro yeah I
don't think I've seen this ever because
when I cover top games none of the top
players fall for this
so yeah it's a very very annoying point
is though of course the pawn is pinned
and now you have to play something like
Queen B4 to just stay in the game and
then you allow be captures an A2 and of
course if you capture just Knight
captures and you are dead here you
cannot recapture so yeah he missed that
pawn to B4 move it's still playable but
I've blundered my advantage here after
all of this I remain in the lead Knight
f captures captures uh and Knight yeah
okay so Knight D5 still uh perfectly
playable Knight D5 yeah okay Rook here
H5 and now okay the engine wants F6 I
play G6 as uh there's one really awesome
game by tall where he played the G6
Follow by H6 and I I thought it was
really really difficult to defend
this uh knight5 okay we capture here
yeah was it was it the best move yeah it
was the best move here captures captures
ah Bishop H6 was better Bishop H6
actually made in 11 Rook captures on G7
isn't made in 11 but it is just as
winning uh yeah oh Bishop G7 right away
ha yeah yeah yeah yeah Bishop G7 King
captures and Rook to G1 check uh and now
you're dead lost yeah because if you go
here then Queen H6
wow threatening mate and yeah that's the
thing with the Knight covering the these
two squares you will have to play and
then Knight captures on F6 also gains
access to G8 you're going to go here
yeah that's a pointless move yeah that's
this is better captures and now captures
with another queen and let's say
Checkmate so uh a lot of stuff possible
here so yeah I could have I could have
gone for Bishop to G7 check right away I
play Rook G1 missing tactics here but
yeah now I find the mate and that's
pretty much it yeah it's made in five
from here yeah not uh not bad uh much
better than the previous game that I
played and here yeah this uh Knight to
G3 move up until this point I'm much
better the engine says like plus 1.5
1.3 uh but yeah obviously you cannot
allow this have to play B3 so if you
play if you face the nro if if you play
H3 the Adams attack uh you should know
something like this yeah I've never seen
it but for for for obvious reasons uh so
yeah uh that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it another Daily Game behind us
we won some rating points uh climbing
back up to that 2200 we'll see how long
it takes us to to get there uh so yeah
that's the game hope you guys enjoyed it
uh see you soon and if you have any
suggestions for me what you would like
me to play Maybe in the next games uh
use hashtag suggestion uh see you
soon